neighbors tell us the most recent street
racing happened last night near grand
canyon and gown road madison kimbrough
is live with what one family describes
as a terrifying ordeal madison
street racing in this northwest valley
neighborhood is nothing new but
according to neighbors last night on new
year's eve it brought it to a whole new
level take a look
i would like to see more of a police
presence in that area even though we do
have the police substation quite nearby
putting up cameras might be very very
helpful a plea from a daughter after her
parents and their neighbors in this
northwest valley neighborhood went
through quite the scare new year's eve
when this happened
crowds of people swarmed the area of
grand canyon and gowen cars racing up
and down the block at all hours of the
night stacy brown says her mom carrie
took this video i was quite infuriated
after watching that because i mean
she could have been killed anybody
around there could have been killed
from what she described to me is that
there was seemed like 200 people they
were blocking off each entrance when
carey sites called police she was told
to get their license plates but says it
was hard to she feared she might get hit
or threatened it was terrifying to get
up as close as i could i thought it was
going to the car was just going to crane
towards the group that i was trying to
stand behind these individuals were
doing these 360s and fast it was so fast
they could have lost control at any time
in fact at some points i thought these
kids were going to get killed metro
released their dui count from new year's
eve with a reported 12 check-ins on
racing something kerry says she hopes
will happen more often so incidents like
this will stop it's so disrespectful and
it just feels like it's escalating and
if they're not being held accountable i
don't feel that there's going to be an
end to it
and right now you're looking at pieces
that are left on the street neighbors
also shared that this incident looked
organized with people using professional
cameras to film which is a commonality
with these racing groups who often post
their videos to youtube later on
reporting live in northwest las vegas
madison kimbrough live local now